yeah how about them pete how about them
tampa bay bucks
huh how about the buccaneers
how about the [ __ ] of [ __ ] new years
are going to the goddamn
super bowl
well that answers that whole oh tom
brady's not that good he was just in
belichick's system
turns out tom brady was very good
not so much not that belichick's a bad
coach a great coach but let's
not now we're realizing that because
it's funny because i actually saw during
the game they were like
the [ __ ] coach of the bucks is like
no i just let tom brady coach the
offense it's like it's totally fine
and he's winning
[Laughter]
and he won and he's going to the zoo and
against kansas city whatever
look i i i book as a dolphins fan i
shouldn't be rooting for the bills but i
was rooting for the bills
i understand it's not rational i'm not
saying that it's reasonable
i i i understand
that i i get it i am not this isn't
something that i'm like
i'm coming from like you know oh because
of this or that i don't know what it is
but i [ __ ] am over mahomes
i can't stand him he's done nothing to
me he's probably a nice guy
i don't know what it is about the guy
and it's not because he's winning
there's people that i hate that are
losers too so let's get that
[ __ ] so it's oh you're just mad
because he's winning i like winners as a
matter of fact
big fan of like a brett favre you know
with peyton manning
[ __ ] winners i'm just over my homes i
don't know maybe it's haircut
i don't know what it may be because he's
like i don't in every commercial and
he's
terrible actor i i'm not really sure
what it is but am i over patrick mahomes
i
really am he's a punchable face that's
right he has a very punchable face i i
don't know what it is
now i understand that there's a lot of
people that are really mad at listen
look
nobody nobody should probably hate brady
more than dolphins fans he was in our
division he beat her ass all the [ __ ]
time
i gotta tell you man i'll be honest with
you
and i'm not a buccaneers fan okay so
let's keep that in mind i i am i'm a
dolphins fan
so i know it's sad but i'm gonna say
this and this is important
i've turned a corner on brady good for
him man 43 years old pulling that [ __ ]
off
good for [ __ ] tom brady good for you
tom
i'm clean living beautiful wife
throwing touchdowns
[ __ ] yeah good for you tom good for
[ __ ] you
and i'm not gonna become a bucks fan be
a buccaneers fan just because
tom brady's on the team that's i
wouldn't do that but i'm just saying
tom brady yes patrick mahomes i'm
[ __ ] done with the guy
i'm done with him i cannot stand seeing
his
face on everything and it's kind of like
no patrick holmes is a great quarterback
but jesus christ he's like
the these these [ __ ] all these sports
analysts and
like i i they just suck this guy's dick
so
much they just suck his [ __ ] dick
like all the time and i'm like
all right we get it he's the second
coming of jesus christ shut up
shut the [ __ ] up
look tom brady is great but even this
early in tom brady's career
when he'd won one super bowl one when
you when first super bowl
they weren't sucking his dick as much as
they're sucking patrick mahomes dick
i don't know what it is about him maybe
it's his face
maybe i'm sick of hearing about him i am
over him
i am over him bucks only won because the
packers
like stop coping don't come in here to
cope the bucks won
because [ __ ] they played good defense
so let's start with that i watched the
whole game
the bucks won because they played good
defense stop
stop simping for [ __ ] aaron rodgers
aaron i've only won
at one nfc championship game rogers okay
rogers is a fantastic quarterback again
i get it
i had a team with a fantastic
quarterback hi my team had dan marino
never won a super bowl so shut up but
stop
the bucks have a good team you don't
make it to the nfc championship game
without having a good team
oh ooh oh backers through the game no
they didn't
the buccaneers beat him bury it
bury it
all right tom brady went in there and he
whoops some ass and honestly their
[ __ ] bucks defense is very good
it's very very good don't worry execute
footballs we'll talk about the bachelor
or whatever stuff you watch and you say
it's ironic but it's not ironic
executing strikes me as somebody who
watches really dumb shows
but then she's like no but i just
watched like ironically to make fun of
it but you know she likes it
you know she's a [ __ ] fan of the
bachelor or like real housewives of
orange county which is ah
watching a goof on it but she like knows
all the story lines
so stop [ __ ] stop
what's kim kardashian up to i don't care